it's not the easiest all the time
but i'm so
ready to like make history bachelorette
villain
luke parker is going to have to pay a
pretty penny for a breaching contract
to me that's like well what yep the
reality star who quickly became the
season 15 bad boy while vying for the
heart of hannah brown
had a judgment against him upheld
recently
and he's on the hook for 100 thousand
dollars
yikes i didn't have a heads up in my
brain
that that was gonna come out nzk
productions inc
the company behind the hit abc dating
series
first filed a petition against the 25
year old in may
after they claim he violated his
contract
the judge at the time awarded the
company the damages requested
and in june nzk productions filed a
motion to confirm the amount
awarded well the company's bid to
enforce the 100 000
judgment against him was approved on
september 30th
and nzk productions filed the unopposed
motion to confirm the arbitration award
and fyi for the non-lawyers out there
that means that nzk productions will
have the opportunity to collect that
hundred grand from luke
that's a lot to unpack luke's contract
with the company which was
agreed upon and finalized in january
2019
forbid him from making any unauthorized
media appearances between the time the
contract was signed
and one year after the broadcast date of
the final episode of his season
which would have been july 2020. you can
see where this is going right
yeah he made several media appearances
that were not authorized by nzk
productions
between september and october 2019 and
further breached the conditions of his
contract by speaking
negatively about the show and its
production i don't want to get into the
misconstrued and be misunderstood thing
luke first gained infamy during hannah
brown's season of the bachelorette
after a convo between him and hannah
escalated into a heated argument about
morality
and having sex before marriage honestly
like what you're saying that the words
that you're saying are just like
really not okay and luke didn't back
down during the bachelorette men tell
all
yes i did have a lot of pride and i was
very arrogant on this show when et
caught up with the show's host chris
harrison
shortly after the men tell all taping he
weighed in on all that
i wanted to kind of have this level of
debate of religion and belief and how
you apply it to your life and
how he applied it to hannah and how he
shamed her made her feel
shamed how he changed the direction of
her show
in my opinion i don't think he got any
of it i think
he needs time i think in his world
life is black and white in the real
world there's a big gray area in the
middle i don't think he's found the gray
area of life and i would just say to him
find the gray area luke it's beautiful